vladimir putin rompió un silencio que
duró casi seis semanas en su primera
declaración pública relacionada
directamente con la crisis con quien
desde el 23 de diciembre el presidente
ruso planteó la posibilidad de que
ucrania sea admitida en la otan un
escenario que para él desencadenaría un
conflicto bélico
putin aseguró que sigue abierto al
diálogo pero acusó a las potencias
occidentales de crear un escenario para
la guerra
no vemos un reconocimiento genuino de
nuestras tres demandas claves impedir la
expansión de la otan cancelar el
despliegue de armas cerca de las
fronteras rusas y devolver las
instalaciones militares del bloque a sus
posiciones en
1997 cuando se firmó el acta fundacional
de rusia
recién a la casa blanca mantiene una
posición inflexible en especial en lo
relativo a la expansión de la otan hacia
el este de europa
no sabemos que va a ser el presidente
putin y es nuestra responsabilidad y un
imperativo mantener la puerta de la
diplomacia abierta a datos es nada
mienta we are going to be
eso no implica que no vamos a defender
nuestros propios valores que incluyen
nuestra creencia y la de los países de
la otan de que depende de los miembros
de la otan determinar quién puede unirse
y esa puerta debe permanecer abiertas y
montenegro en la mayor ciudad sirve open
las apuestas hasta el momento apuntan a
la vía diplomática el primer ministro
británico boris johnson fue hasta aquí
para mostrar su solidaridad al
presidente ucraniano volodymyr selenski
desde donde aseguró que una eventual
invasión rusa ucrania representaría un
desastre y en conversación paralela pero
telefónica el canciller ruso sérguei
lávrov reiteró su posición a su homólogo
estadounidense anthony blinken moscú ha
concentrado más de 100 mil soldados en
la frontera mientras que el que ha
llamado a no sembrar el pánico anunció
que aumentará sus fuerzas armadas en
100.000 efectivos durante los próximos
tres años